one purpose world to her promo pic three  shots with his friends and eight  smoldering selfies who which are  shirtless yet no one says I'm back like  Bieber over the course of a 10 hour  period Justin post on Instagram 12 times  his most like shot is this one in front  of the mirror where he captions it so  much content for the most surprising  part of it all is that Justin had  already made his return five days ago  hello i'm justin bieber on Super Bowl  weekend Justin was contractually  obligated to post his t-mobile  commercial and endorsement that found  the singer collecting a reported two  million dollars but a sneaky return went  highly unnoticed by the majority of his  80 million followers with the exception  of his most hardcore believers  [Music]